first vote of season 42.
i'll take the shot
any votes cast for zach will still count
second person voted out of survivor 42.
zack that's three that's enough you need
to bring me your torch zach thank you
for joining us oh thank you so much you
were the first player voted out of
survivor 42. how are you feeling right
now i'm feeling great honestly i really
felt like you know this happened a while
ago zach travis spoke
i've gotten to process it got to like
work through all the emotions i just got
voted out of survivor and it's just fun
that i finally got to see the experience
play out now be past it what does it
take to win survivor
i think we're about to find out jack
so do you have any regrets about your
gameplay is there anything that you
would change if you got to do it again i
think that i would have talked a lot
more with drea because her name was out
there so much i kind of thought i didn't
want to align myself with a sinking ship
but i don't think i realized how much
power she really had out there
specifically with romeo and roxroy i
didn't even realize they were working
together because they butted head so
often